really special occasion in in honor of
how Conklin for so many people in this
room he played a very special role in
our lives I want to just I'm going to
really keep my remarks very brief but
I'd wanted to just acknowledge that some
think that this is mostly an event for
the the Yale community and and the the
Yale anthropology department and other
academic departments he had but I wanted
to acknowledge also some of the the
progeny of his sister which are in I
don't have a proper anthropological
diagram with with a triangles and
circles but the the the SU Cisco progeny
and and significant others can you raise
your hands and so you can there you go
all right and then also a my brother and
his family are sitting right here and
then my own family is here and then
we're right there there you go
a cluster so we're going to adjust it
just to give you an idea of the program
we're going to try to ask the speakers
to really keep their remarks to a
minimum so that we have an opportunity
to really visit at the reception and
there's a lot of people who haven't seen
each other in a long time or people I
just met actually and which is which is
but I've read about and and seen
so after this that we'll be going to the
reception in the Great Hall where really
some spectacular dinosaurs are and so
without further ado I'm just going to
introduce and Underhill and is the the
chair of the department of anthropology
and
really was has been a tremendous
supporter in in not only my father and
keeping his ridiculous amount of space
during the time that he was a professor
here but also really supporting the the
transfer and the organization of those
mature of of the massive amounts of
materials that that he accumulated over
the years so that it could be it could
be archived in this terrific museum and
then the other museum facilities in West
Haven so and she's been also very
supportive of of this reception so and
could you come safety more remark
[Applause]
welcome everyone my colleagues in the
Department of Anthropology and I along
with my fellow peabody museum curators
and friends from the southeast asian
studies council are really grateful for
the opportunity to celebrate with you
the remarkable career and legacy of
professor Harold Conklin and not to be
forgotten of course as well are the many
contributions of Jean Conklin we are
honored by the presence of so many
family members friends fellow students
and colleagues of Hal's from near and
far including the Philippines and other
Yale colleagues present today are from
the Gail University Library who has
contributed so much to the legacy as
well we have many people to thank for
today's event in the brand new David
friend Hall in addition to the Conklin
family especially Peabody Museum
director David Skelly and you'll hear
from him in a moment it seems to me that
anthropology is a discipline that aims
to bring together different worlds of
meaning and understanding few scholars
have achieved so many insights with such
attention to detail enthusiasm and
energy as Harold Conklin when I walk
down the stairs from my office on the
second floor of the 51 Hillhouse Avenue
building and look at house office below
I can still see the joy on his face as
he looks at his notes and he stares with
pleasure at the stunning photos he took
of the Philippines on the wall I will
think of that every single time I go
down the stairs as long as I'm working
here I will wrap up these remarks
because everyone is eager to share
memories of our colleague and friend Hal
Conklin although we all miss the
unforgettable individual my Yale
colleagues and I are very grateful to
Pat affably
and everyone in the Department of
Anthropology
I should say the Anthropology Division
of the Peabody Museum and many of these
people are here today for working so
hard to preserve the rich material
record of Howl's legacy for generations
to come
thank you next is that David Skelly who
is the director of the Peabody Museum of
Natural History where we are now and
importantly really the the museum and
the museum staff have really taken on
the role of the primary keepers of the
materials and we're very grateful for
that thanks Bruce so let me add my
welcome to you all
it's wonderful to see you all here here
today on such an important occasion
Bruce Conklin was one of us
here in the museum for for many years
and we we miss him terribly as I know
all of you do as well I speak on behalf
of the curators and the staff and many
students who've passed through here over
a long period of time and I'll also say
on behalf of my myself
Bruce was somebody I've been associated
with the museum for almost 20 years and
first knew Bruce sorry first knew Hal as
a an emeritus an emeritus curator but
nevertheless and extremely involved
emeritus curator who attended every
single curators meeting and
did not sit idly by he was a frequent
contributor to the discussions of the
meetings his comments were always to the
point and he always I think had the
larger goals of the museum firmly in
mind my interactions with how we're
almost exclusively in that forum you
know one hour a month over over many
years until one night I was in Manhattan
for you know what for me was kind of a
big deal occasion I'd been awarded a
Guggenheim Fellowship I went to this
reception at the Foundation and I was
walking through this this kind of
crowded cocktail sort of scene and I
recognized the kind of gravelly voice
going do I know you
and I introduced myself and he goes oh
yes and how kind of took me by the arm
and introduced me to a whole bunch of
people who are attending there some of
whom I am still in contact with because
of that and then my wife was with me and
he took both of us out to dinner at the
oyster bar during the period before they
stopped smoking in restaurants in New
York so I have a very clear memory of
the lower half of house tie with the
pall of smoke down to about here we had
a wonderful meal a wonderful
conversation and that deepen our our
friendship and I remember him is just a
wonderful colleague and I'll quickly
yield to people who I know want to share
their thoughts but I just want to say
representing again the museum that
housed legacy here is deeply important
and there are conversations going on
right now about how we can make sure
that the impact of his work and the the
wonderful story that he's put together
about the cultures they that he studied
so lovingly and so for for so long is
not forgotten and continues to remain
many things including a resource for
future generations of scholars so thank
you again for being here
[Applause]
bill Kelly is next there we go
and who was the chair of anthropology
actually when my mother died and for the
fourth this a similar sort of event for
my mother with we're really grateful for
how supportive he was through it for our
whole family now and then thank you very
much and it's it's a real pleasure
albeit bittersweet to be participating
today and beyond the other people whom
we do want to thank particularly Bruce
and Mark and the extended family for all
the assistance and leadership in making
this occasion and others possible I was
talking with Hal on a Friday afternoon
November 28 2008 in the hallway of 51
Hill House and I mentioned that day
because that was the day that Claude
Livy strokes turned 100 and this was a
cause of national celebration in France
and it had been for months and the film
crews and the scholars from there I've
been beating a path to his door there
were exhibits and on that day and even
before that day he had basically shut
himself up in his apartment with his
wife and tried to avoid this media crush
that had been going building and
building and building and we were
talking about this and how mention not
boastfully but just in passing that he
had been on the telephone with Claude
lévi-strauss that morning to wish him my
hundredth birthday and they were talking
and it turned out that on his hundredth
birthday that was the only telephone
call that Claude lévi-strauss took and
wanted to take he had no other contact
with the world beyond that phone call
and you know it speaks to the vast
network of scholars through which hal
traveled with such exceptional influence
and regard from his earliest years
remember this little boy from Patchogue
was was made a member of the aqua sonic
mohawk at the age of 8 and when he was a
teenager he was giving advice to
Margaret Mead in the American Museum of
Natural History about some of the
collections and he was an
anthropological child prodigy the likes
of which I can't name a single other the
other reason I mentioned that particular
conversation on November 28th was
because there are several of us here
today who had been chair of the
anthropology department in the 1980s and
1990s and we all remember that the
number one financial headache and
diplomatic challenge of being chair was
house telephone bill now
to the younger members of the audience
back then there was long distance from
landlines and it was very expensive
and the department was given a very
limited budget each year by the
University and we carefully parceled it
out at one point I think we were each
given fifty dollars a year in
long-distance and a ledger was kept and
how blue passed the entire department
budget for the year no within three or
four months I suppose a close second to
the the chairs headache was ensuring a
constant supply of Blackfeet Indian
writing company number two cedar wood
soft LED pencils which we had to procure
by the grouse and became more difficult
after 1992 when the tribal company
passed into private hands but it was
really the telephone bill that exercised
it far into the night
you know utterly promiscuous how would
be in there talking in multiple
languages to Edmund leach at King's
College or a geologist at Padua or an
ethno botanist in in Borneo or a mohawk
elder and aquas on e or philippine
colleagues up and down that country or
in the diaspora around the world he was
in touch constantly he was a global
scholar before global became a buzzword
there's no way that we could or would
want as chair to cut off his umbilical
phone line and so the chairs job was to
frantically and furtively move our
meager funds around as best we could
sort of like a carnival shell game plead
with Ray Novak at the end of the year to
overlook that column in the budget and
otherwise enable this way in which how
connected to the world of course for
most of us locally the students and
colleagues and the steady stream of
visitors from around the world
it was our face time in his office
behind that padded door the decibel
level dropped
about 20 as you closed the door and sat
down on one of those two straight back
chairs separated from him by that
gunmetal Steelcase desk no-nonsense an
office that had no wasted space but was
never cluttered always orderly and the
manila folder that sat on the desk
between Howe and myself that he kept on
and for each of us with precise penciled
notes that were small and just small
enough you couldn't really read to see
what was on that not as a means of
surveillance but as a running agenda of
all of the things that he wanted to ask
all of the things he wanted to share all
of the issues he wanted to discuss at
our periodic meetings it was a list that
was never exhausted it always got longer
over the decades that I had the
privilege of knowing him as his
staggering area addition as you see from
the handout as you know from your own
encounters over many years as you will
hear today we're stoked by a polymorphic
a curiosity and a linguistic virtuosity
and an unrelenting activity but unlike
his friend Levy Stros his was a generous
active insatiable engagement with lives
being lived and not an avaricious and
and detached collection of traces of
lived lives he carried his Airy addition
lightly I think and he shared it without
showing us it was in the interest of our
understanding and not his ego his prose
was absolutely precise without ever
being dry and it was evocative without
ever being florid now hal has long been
celebrated for his prodigious powers of
description in all its finest no doubt
this is true but this way of putting his
gifts
has always made me a bit nervous because
it can unwittingly sustain the binary
all-too-common place as pernicious as it
is pervasive between what's called
description and what's called analysis
and the insidious privilege of the
latter over the former this is not it at
all in our drive to understand the
fullness of social life and the human
condition there are how questions and
there are why questions and how has
asked more and more probing how
questions and provided us with more and
richer how answers than any other
anthropologist before since thank you
very much
[Applause]
so that next is whose work actually
probably comes closest to some of how
work let's see if I can get on the slide
here I'm hoping that this comes on here
sorry you just have to up there we go
there we go okay I'll sit on the side
and how do I advance as long as you say
next I can do that so thank you for
extending this honor to me - to speak
here this this afternoon
so yeah fairly good there we go okay all
right there goes the basis for a
class-action suit by Tom so this is the
Conklin doorbell at 106 York Square
place that was not an applause line Jean
Conklin once told me a story about the
day this doorbell broke and so a
doorbell repairman had to come by to fix
it you can guess what happened next
house started to interview the repairmen
about doorbells Jeanne said for heaven's
sakes Hal it's just the doorbell but for
how nothing was just the doorbell his
genius in the field lay precisely in
seeing the complexity in the mundane
dimensions of everyday life that the
rest of us pass over what he called the
beauty of the internal logic of complex
cultural systems whether it involved
felling a tree next
I could do that okay and there or
managing a swidden cycle Hal's precision
what Chuck Frey called the fineness of
his description in the wonderful fesh
rift by Joel Kuiper's who's with us
today and Ray McDermott this was
intuitively convincing for audiences as
diverse as Claude lévi-strauss and the
Food and Agriculture Organization of the
UN the 1957 monograph on the hana no'eau
that that held published with the FAO
definitively refuting the hegemonic
misunderstanding of swidden agriculture
may have been the most politically
impactful work of mid 20th century
American anthropology unremarked by how
in that less self-reflexive era the
goodness of his ethnography was clearly
founded on his love for the people he
worked with he didn't that's the wrong
slide there we go
there are no photos of hell in the field
typing all by himself in his tent like
like like evans-pritchard or whoever or
Clifford
Marcus Weber how is always with people
usually laughing the shared humor did
not suspend his critical ethnographers
ear however as when Hal observed that
the rhyming couplets shouted out by Han
inaudibly parties are quote unquote
almost always amusing and you just know
that he was keeping count
following up on Bill Kelly's boo Kelly
did the economic side of this house late
night telephone calls were famous
typically beginning with the comment
upon a mutual acquaintance
perhaps shifting to his or her mentor
than to a colleague of that person and
to a student of that colleague spiraling
off into the wider anthropological
universe eventually closing the loop
after an hour or two or not depending
upon how early you had to get up the
next day try this once more so indeed if
howl is looking down upon us now looking
at this this audience he sees not
individuals but interlinked actors all
drawn together in the great adventure of
anthropology all of us trying our best
to follow in his footsteps
Eugene hung in the in the kuipers
mcdermid Festschrift asked was Conklin
that much better in the field than we
and he answered his own question with a
very interesting elaborate historical
cultural ecological explanation
the simpler truth of course is yes how
was that much better and he will be
missed
and perhaps none of us should ever look
again at a doorbell in quite the same
way thank you let me just so let me see
if I can get this right here I can be
assured that nobody's going to be as
tall as Michael dub in the next anyhow
so the the next speaker is Pat of Bob
lay my father met Pat when she was a
high school teacher in in the
Philippines and had an interest though
in ethnography a couple years later she
found herself as a as a graduate student
here at Yale and was and has been really
close sort of essentially a member of
our family and in many ways and
particularly in the in the in his most
recent years in the last five to ten
years I think that we've had been just
hugely indebted to Pat and and how she's
she's really the person who knows my
father's collection better than anybody
else and really knows his work and and
really him better than anyone else in
terms of the the Anthropology has been
really it meant a tremendous amount to
our family that she's dedicated so much
time for that so Pat
[Applause]
thank you Bruce
the few times that Hal referred to
himself as a Filipina Stan area studies
scholar was in regard to the three
philippine languages tagalog hana no and
if you go to which he devoted many years
of energetic study so today i just like
to say something about health languages
and his study of language we have all
probably read that mohawk of course was
the first language that hal learned
outside of his family circle this was in
the summer camps in upstate New York
that he attended with speakers of
Iroquois and languages the value of
language as secret code and thus
performance of course was very important
in his relationship to his sister
Suzanne with whom Hal shared many Mohawk
songs as well as other forms of arcane
knowledge
so while william fenton introduced how
the seneca and floyd Lansbury taught him
some Onida it was really more hot the
mohawk of health teenage years that was
charged most heavily with emotional the
emotional meanings of his closest
personal relationships language as
secret code and as puzzles stayed with
Hal all of his life sometimes really
exasperatingly for people who have to
read his field notes and his journals as
he expanded his knowledge of philippine
languages and scripts this habit became
even more pronounced more pervasive and
perverse really he he assured me many
times that the keys to these codes
somewhere in 51 Hillhouse but they're
not really there to be
during during health second year as a
soldier in the Philippine bill in the
military during the Second World War he
moved into the household of the eminent
Filipino sculptor and art professor
later national artist Guillermo
talentino
who basically adapted hell and taught
him the eloquent Bulacan variety of
Tagalog that how spoke until his last
year's he spoke Tagalog to all of the
Filipino nurses and nurse aids and
security detail in the in the very the
couple of retirement homes where he
lived in Manila in the late 1940s how
became a poster boy for foreigners
learning Tagalog his pictures appearing
in local newspapers and magazines with
examples of his exquisite speech and
writing Tolentino also encouraged how to
to study old Tagalog writing and other
indict derived scripts of the
Philippines
so while house Mindoro work is really
best known today for its focus on
swidden agriculture it was actually
because he discovered an index script in
Yaga and met liu yun and Bedok
that he decided to stay on there for a
while
throughout his life how pursued ritual
kinship bonds with descendants of his
academic ancestors and other teachers
this is the only way I can explain his
interest in leonard bloomfield assistant
for example in 1917 how followed he
sought out Santiago's Alfred o
Santiago's descendant in in Blokhin and
in Manila and was very interested in
what they might know about their
ancestor who had provided Bloomfield
with his massive volume of texts that
became the basis of his Tagalog grammar
hal went to Humber to look
to look for Auto temples granddaughter
for example he went to tea copia after
boning up on on Raymond first texts of
course to look for descendants of Bremen
first assistance from the 1930s
so as we shall see this fascination
about ancestors and their links to their
descendants resonated beautifully with
the long genealogical recitations of the
ifugao so at the end of house first
decade in if Ogawa I realized during a
visit there that he had apprenticed
himself to orator x' to learn a ritual
invocation called egg gaupa this is a
stylized tale told between dances at the
feast with a good with in a highly
emphatic hyperbolic mode and with a good
amount of foot stomping it's it's about
an ancestor who journeys into the lower
world where he walks in unending lush
forests teeming with fruit and wild game
along banks of rivers of crystal-clear
water this account as we would expect
for house favorite verbal performance is
filled with ritual names of trees other
plants river fish and wildlife and then
at the end of this tale the storyteller
in the ritual escorts the ancestor back
to this place to vine in on to this
named place and he shifts to the present
tense he shifts all of his his whole
demonstrative language and the ancestor
is here now bringing the blessings of
his fabled travels and bestows not only
well-being and overflowing granaries to
his descendants but also safe paths in
the clarity of purpose that crystal
clear waters symbolized for many
northern
leapin people's and how after a bit more
white rice wine than usual he turned to
me and he said stomping his feet of
course it doesn't get any better than
this so sure enough more than a decade
later
wen Hao went to Paris to receive the
facin prize and deliver Eric a lecture
in French he recited a go pass at the
end of his lecture bringing the
blessings of I mean arms ancestors to
Paris to the very hall where Professor
levy Stroh's had arrived to come to hear
him so now as we tell tales of health
exuberant journeys to places of lush
beauty of verbal artistry and abundant
harvests of many many different kinds we
can name him as an ancestor right here
now and can say yes it's true it's true
how it doesn't get any better than this
thank
[Applause]
that was great it's true that he I we
actually for our children actually
wanted they we realized that we couldn't
have them understand their grandfather
unless they saw him in the field because
he was that's when he was at his peak
so Bertini anderson is that is the next
speaker she was a bit of a person of
lore actually in our house the she was
the graduate student who went off to the
Laplanders and then we would have to
field calls from her family who are
saying and my mother I remember my
mother explaining that yes she would
come back someday ah ha ha and then when
she did come back
she was also it was a tremendous with us
in terms of sharing a family of patas
and lorises and particularly potters
with us as kids and so merdeen well I
don't have anything prepared but then
I've never been prepared for anything in
my entire life I have this year and also
last year written small pieces about how
just coincidentally one since his death
and in one year ago which was supposed
to have been due two years before that
but and and I have those on a stick
drive and there I can share them with
anyone that wants them so I don't want
to repeat myself because if you want to
read these pieces one is super titled
the joy of ethnography which I think
captures what people have been saying
about how and the other one a a
Montessori for ethnography because he
was so interested in everything
including the census
and in fact one of his categories in
that bibliography a full classification
bibliography that I was privileged to do
the footwork on one of the categories
had to do with sense experience no
surprise that he was interested in color
also no surprise that I made for him in
the field from Lapland a tie that I wove
myself with the plant died materials I
on a loom that I made myself in the Sami
fashion that's the lapis fashion I made
my own loom but they don't dye things
they're only interested in colors that
are red and blue that our annalen dyes
but I plant died these things and I made
a tie for how and oddly enough whenever
he knew we would intersect
he had that tie on I don't know how he
managed he was always in Brownian motion
his mind was in Brownian motion and what
resonates most in all of the offline and
a formal comments here today has been
his telephone usage incessant
I figured that he was on the phone all
the time because he had friends in every
single time zone on the earth and that
meant you had to have an appointment
with your major professor that could be
a little bit odd it might be 3:30 in the
afternoon but it could be 3:30 in the
morning and it was all the same to him
he would also call us of course but then
you were you had to sort of put aside
all of your other needs including you're
eating and you're drinking and you're
sleeping and your bathroom breaks until
he was finished but you couldn't predict
when that was because he always had
his own agenda now I just want to close
with one probe because I'm hoping
someone here can give me this
information I realized that I only had
received this story when I came to Yale
and I never researched it he researched
everything everything but but I just
accepted stories and when I went to tell
them again I hadn't researched them well
here's the story evidently before my
time which would be before 1968 a group
within the anthropology department had
some kind of a a roast and I don't think
it was only about how but I think
students were were ridiculing in in
proper roasting fashion their superiors
and I was told that someone but who that
person was I do not know maybe you can
tell me someone came out and
impersonated how this person had strings
of wire coat hangers strong off each
other such that they had to be held up
this high and they created taxonomy x'
and typology x' and maybe even paradigms
and keys and indices and the the
impersonator was able to mimic how hell
would interpret that string of coat
hangers so I'm going to end with that
and just ask you please can you tell me
who did that
[Applause]
so Bobcats Berg is is next and he he has
some particularly insights in terms of
how in the Honda know well before I
begin I'm going to ad-lib a little bit
ok those telephone calls to me in
Indianapolis Indiana and 30 year old
undergraduate at a school called IUPUI
about once a month would always begin
Bob are you awake and of course I wasn't
because it's about 1:00 1:30 in the
morning sure how what's up I only have 5
or 10 minutes and an hour and a half
later well I've got to get oh my gosh at
time it is he was hysterical and my
second ad-lib is the doorbell he so
frustrated that doorbell repair person
that when he left the doorbell didn't
work anyway by the time I arrived in
southern Mindoro in the late 70s how was
known affectionately as lucky son Glenn
okay
grandfather Conklin alright and I was a
Peace Corps volunteer I was working in
the far western reaches of their
homeland with a sub group called the
goobot noon and they had never
personally met how but they had a lot of
stories about him his fame had traveled
how it appears was a Navy fighter pilot
who was shot down over Mindoro by the
Japanese and was rescued by the Hana no
they took him put him in a cave and they
nurtured him back to health and that is
why the only reason that he came back to
live among them to become part of their
kinship he was adopted by the Hana no it
was outta gratitude for them rescuing
him okay so when I told how this story
when he came to visit me as a Peace
Corps volunteer
we met in San Jose Occidental Mindoro
Hal had that great laugh he
roared with that howl Conklin laughter
and said absolutely not he was not in
the Navy he was in the army he didn't
fly claims he was an infantryman however
there was a story a true story that a
Navy pilot was shot down over Mindoro in
the Hana no rescued this person an
urchin back to health and kept him from
the Japanese so they had merged these
two stories together I used to visit the
yago area Bedok I actually met Bedok in
person his family wonderful and they
held they considered how the family
member he wasn't just a friend he was a
family member and they had a lot of
affection and a lot of great stories
about him I'm sure they're embellished
to a degree but for those of us who know
him I'll let you judge whether or not
these are embellished one was the man
never slept he was up all hours at night
going through all the materials he had
collected and the people he was never
alone he was never alone always had
somebody with him going over everything
so that brings us to the next point they
could not believe his insatiable
curiosity about everything it was
unbelievable that they could a plant he
would it was he was phenomenal and they
loved it because when it came to the
plant world especially they had that
same kind of love and knowledge that
they shared with him the third thing was
actually kind of interesting he could
carry a hundred pounds on his back and
run up the mountain and this was in his
younger days of course just after World
War two and they talked about how
physically strong he was which went
along with with his ability to to stay
up all night and he never lost energy
that was what was so interesting about
it was he never lost energy so I'd like
to end by talking a little bit about
what how Conklin meant to me I was a
late 20 year old in the Peace Corps
never been to college before high school
graduate
had some questions about Hana no culture
they just couldn't get to I was pretty
fluent in the language so I dared write
this professor at Yale University a
letter asking him some questions
wondering about what would he think of
the Peace Corps volunteer a high school
graduate all that he wrote back a letter
that had to been 10 pages long and then
told me he was coming to Mindoro and
wanted to meet with me I don't know what
he saw in me because I didn't have a
real lot of confidence in myself in
terms of academia especially but he
encouraged me to go to college and he
called me once a month for four years
making sure I was doing what I needed to
do to get into University and I did a
large part to him I'm sure but I got in
i enjoyed it absolutely loved it here I
had access to him anytime I wanted
access he was a phenomenal mentor to me
and it goes a little further after I
came back from the field in 1992 I went
through a divorce to the woman I was
married with Hana know woman how called
me every week every week making sure I
was doing okay making sure I was working
on my dissertation I was teaching
anthropology three sections and
anthropology at IUPUI was it was taking
care of my sons it was it was a tough it
was tough but how was there for me and I
don't know that I would have ever
finished that dissertation had he not
cared so much about me so I'll end on a
little more humorous note I would have
finished that Dern dissertation six
months earlier if he hadn't been so damn
crazy about the maps
he drove me crazy about those maps and
it was just vintage Halligan being are
you sure you've checked this the
contours don't look right something so I
say goodbye to a friend and a great
mentor I wouldn't be in the position
that I am today if it wasn't for I'll
complain thank you so Joel Kuiper's is
it is the next speaker and he edited and
helped put together a book which is
about 500 pages long called fine
description which really was a
compilation of how of my father's work
and it was a huge it was a huge gift to
our family in particular because 80% of
that work I didn't know anything about
and so to have a description of it
because he had mostly been working on
the Atlas for for my childhood and so
for for for him for for Joel and his and
his colleagues many of whom are also
here in the room and contributed to that
book it was it was a tremendous gift to
us and probably into the whole community
[Applause]
yeah thanks Bruce in as Bruce mentioned
in 2007 ray McDermott and I put it put
together a volume of halvah so we called
fine description after chub breaks
phrase many of his essays had been
published in some rather carefully
selected but shall we say out-of-the-way
places and we hope to make them more
accessible to the public and yelled
Southeast Asia Studies was good enough
to publish
I'm grateful for that but as ray and I
reflected on some of the main themes of
Hal's work an anecdote one I know that
merdeen Anderson is also experienced
that stood out to us what we experienced
as part of his legendary ethnography
seminar it was a sort of exercise in
which he laid out before us a kind of
strange-looking vine on the length of
the seminar table in 51 Hill House it's
called a cupboard in the
ilonggo language of luzon this vine and
this is our exercise needed in english
gloss and that was no easy task since
this vine was used among the along
Goethe in the this part of luzon to get
from treetop to treetop when trimming
the upper branches of the jungle canopy
to provide sunlight on the swidden
fields below now I won't go through all
of the struggles that the seminar
participants experienced before we
finally settled on the gloss Pollard in
vine but it was it was kind of
illuminating but also terrifying to try
to figure out how we could come up with
a with a gloss for that I was
interviewed some years later after this
this came out and this story about the
poverty line came up in the and the
person who was interviewing me responded
in the popular phrase that if he goes
poverty mind how is that even a thing I
remembered being initially taken aback
by that by the question and and being
struck that in some ways that employed
seem to apply a kind of ontological
surrender that Hal with his infectiously
enthusiastic curiosity about everything
would never have committed or
countenanced even but on further
reflection I've come to think actually
precisely that's
that's actually a good question that's
precisely the question that al was hell
was asking how are these things actually
a thing he was how how was the tabata
actually a thing he was interested in
overdetermined zones of knowledge the
overlapping joints seams creases in the
fabric of the phenomenal and cultural
world for this reason he was attracted
to things like dictionaries indexes
taxonomies encyclopedias catalogs but
also and largely for the same reason
densely terraced rice fields where
information was thickly inscribed on
mountainsides bamboo internodes where
knowledge of how to do love songs were
fixed into the culture and scraggly
Pollard in vines where a common plant
played an integral role in the process
of shifting cultivate cultivation
agriculture seems to be an era now where
Google is now so off so often the
referee of the question how is that a
thing
how recognise the deep need the catalog
and group together and distinguish the
items of cultural experience and this
process requires us to engage in the
gregarious and often messy but
ultimately satisfying anthropological
business of evaluating and verifying the
thickness of a thing by examining it in
its linguistic and interactive aesthetic
and material context and in the process
of doing this that seemed to me he left
us a big gift he anticipated so many of
the contemporary theoretical debates
that are swirling around in anthropology
today about materiality about discourse
about ethnic graphic representation ways
that we are only now coming to recognize
thanks hell
[Applause]
the next speaker is Ana Labrador and she
came all the way from the Manila
Philippines where she's from the
National Museum of the Philippines were
held and so much of his time thanks
thank you so much for having me here
I must confess I am one of the
recipients of his phone calls with my
very first phone call from him was when
I in 2000 when I was a newly minted PhD
and somehow he found out about me and I
got the phone call at the the department
where I was still teaching at the time
and I thought it was like a hoax you
know how would Harold Conklin call
someone like me cuz I you know I know
how big he was and part of my
dissertation was doing him a survey of
material culture of museums
you know collections in museums that you
know where he had actually given his his
his donated stuff from his field so um
so he called me said I want to have
lunch with you at the Hotel
Intercontinental which was still around
at the time and then I said wow you know
he wants to have lunch with me and then
finally when we got together he said I
want to read your dissertation and I
said oh no I'm going to be examined
again I thought I had passed so you know
he he we had a great debate about it and
he said I didn't write those things that
you were quoting me from so it was good
to have that but anyway I I'm here
really to tell you about his great gift
to the National Museum of the
Philippines he's was wonderful he
started off after the Second World War
when the Bureau of Science burnt down he
helped in reconstructing the Philippine
national herbarium
he collected from 1947 to 1963 and
they're about only about 320 for a
biospecimen that they were so important
they're all about endemic species if you
go and Mindoro and Palau and the various
apiece gone to and he was accompanied by
our researchers who learned a lot from
him he also donated quite a number of
Mindoro a material culture from the area
Hanano and buid some of these are
actually in the exhibition at the we
have a permanent gallery that devoted to
bye-bye in which is the ancient and
traditional scripts of the Philippines
and we've got a little bit of batak
palawan collection also from him which
he collected from 1946 to 1947 these are
all going to be named as The Herald
Conklin memorial collection and so I
prepared the resolution for board of
trustees to sign off on it and when they
read through it they said you cannot
just name the collection as that and so
they've insisted that there will be two
rooms that will be named after him in
the National Museum of the Philippines
so one would be at the National Museum
of Anthropology we've renamed the Museum
of Filipino people as a National Museum
anthropology and the other is a going to
be at the National Museum of Natural
History which will open next year in in
June 12 so you know we wanted to you
know give the certificate of the Harold
Conklin memorial collection but they
told me to hang on and then because
they're determining the space now to in
which you know these two rooms will be
May
after him so what I wanted to do is
actually also end this talk because I'm
the last speaker to show the impact of
dr. Conklin to us at the National Museum
five years ago we started a an
archaeological project in if you go to
determine if his claim that the if ago
rice terraces a kouya 2,000 years old
and so we put out a publication and it
will be available very soon on our
website for everyone to access and we
found out it's not 2000 years old it's
actually 800 years old and but it's a
good thing because it meant really that
from his work we've been inspired to do
other things at the moment we are also
doing an indigo research and and other
other things that still you know even in
our Philippine national herbarium the
National Museum is in charge of that we
want to do more more more work on you
know it's like standing on a giant
shoulder so we would like to thank him
and his family for sharing him with us
so in the same time I'm going to because
our researchers actually prepared the
collection the collection is given to
the National Museum in a in a thumb
drive an external drive and they asked
me to give this to his family so thank
you
[Applause]
okay so that that ends the formal
portion of this program but we actually
the informal portion of the program is
is uh is it just as important the we
will be going to the dinosaur hall or
the Great Hall as it's called and we'll
we can gather there they'll be food and
but we also encourage people to think
about giving a toast there are some
people that I've already talked to but
other people are certainly welcome
there's when putting together this
program there were way too many people
who actually could speak and were very
qualified to speak and to to you know to
put it into an hour-long program but we
we felt that hopefully that we'll be
hearing from several of you during
during that time okay so thank you very
much
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm Dylan I'm house grandson
thank you all for coming
means a lot I'm up here with my mic cut
my sister and my cousin and we're pals
grandchildren so I'm going to give this
toast on behalf of the grandchildren I'd
like to toast our grandfather or as we
referred to him ah boo to us Appa was
the real-life Indiana Jones and in an
afternoon with a boo normally meant
learning how to use a lasso using a bow
and arrow or listening to some of the
many stories that he had collected
throughout the years he would tell us
stories about his childhood and about
how he became fascinated with the Native
Americans at the World's Fair in Chicago
this story about his first date with our
grandmother and the drum and some
drama-filled stories like the time he
was captured by the Philippine police
because they suspected him of being a
Russian spy and he was only able to
escape by getting them drunk and
sneaking away in the night his stories
always had held a feeling of wonder for
the world a feeling that has continued
through all of us he taught us to
question the world we were born into and
inspired us to explore new cultures
internet and ideas but as much as he
liked to adventure often was a creature
of habit and we're and what I miss most
are the morning spent together opera
with the New York Times and a crisp
glass of orange juice asking me about
what I was learning and giving me his
global insights
here's to Appa who will always remember
as the best grandfather anyone could ask
for
thank you
hi I'm Mike Davidson I was a student of
Hal's from 67 to 69 and it's kind of a
personal connection I just want to talk
about just for a minute
um how I connected over a shared love of
the hata knew I was living with Donna
knew was a Peace Corps volunteer and
corresponding with how like broadcast
Berg was in the same way and somehow
managed to come here and study with him
but the thing that happened was I think
how realized pretty soon after my
getting here that I was not cut out for
the academic life and so I I was heard
the story about the ethnography class
well I took the autocracy class but how
let me go off and observe classrooms in
the high school high schools in New
Haven he didn't really expect me to
figure out what a vine was and and what
a vine should be called and then when
when Margaret Mead came looking for a
young graduate student to teach kids in
New York City he said got just the guy
for you but it was that but what
happened was hell took a chance I mean I
was this kid from Brooklyn with no real
academic support at all as his
background he took a chance on me and it
really set my life on its path I learned
enormous amount from him about about all
kinds of things but mostly you know I
think it was somebody who took a chance
so Thank You Hal for life that you gave
me
[Music]
[Applause]
so I hadn't prepared anything and I
hadn't expected to be as emotional as I
feel but my name is kensey Sturdivant
I'm the daughter of William Sturdivant I
would say that my father probably
considered how his best friend
they met in graduate school probably in
the early 50s so for Bruce and Mark and
Ruth and all of us who grew up as
Eurasian children of anthropologists I
have a lot of stories that I'm sure that
resonate with all of you about the
note-taking and the love of language and
always asking why and how even the trash
baskets in our house were labeled with a
collection number and the we were
hearing stories about the early graduate
school paper that my father and how
wrote about the the turtle the shell
rattle and I lived in the Attic of our
house and Chevy Chase and that rattle
was in my closet in my bedroom but and
we shared I know our parents shared
within an Iroquois mask that they agreed
as grad students that every year we
would move they both bought it together
and they agreed they owned it together
and every year it would move from their
house to our house so I have a lot of
memories about what it is to grow up
with an anthropologist and how is not
just an anthropologist but as my
father's friends but I think the point
that is most meaningful to me is that I
was in the first couple of years of
women that were mitad to you and how and
Jean were my parents so I spent a lot of
time here in New Haven babysitting
eating ice cream but but really with
both hal and jean as i think helping me
to manage was probably in the early
years a very difficult early college
experience so you know the the stories i
think that I was hearing today about his
humanity his warmth
yes his curiosity and his intellectual
interest and all that but
the smile the warmth the love you know
that I think I felt as really almost a
surrogate child is really what what
brought that back to me and even today
when I was seeing you know Noll and his
granddaughter wearing a necklace for me
fool doll I have that necklace and I
forgot it
so you know I guess thank you for
organizing this thank you for reminding
me how much he meant to me and just what
a loving and wonderful man he was
[Applause]
hi everybody it's great to be here
I'm Jim tsypko and I was a house nephew
my mother is his sister I'm one of four
they're all here I used to call how
quite a bit at night at 11 o'clock at
night I didn't call the school but we
had many conversations I live on Cape
Cod and I'm a builder so he was very
interested in my like my trade I
appreciated that so he would came up to
the Cape one time and we have a garden
in Sandwich mass called the heritage
plantation it's a large parcel property
that was donated by a family and there's
a lot of species of rhododendrons a lot
of variety of trees he knew every tree
of course and every species of various
plantings so they have a museum there
it's a Quaker Museum it's a Quaker
designed Barn Museum where they have
antique cars so he was intrigued with
that as well as he's everything so we
walked in there and antique cars or
you're not supposed to go near him right
look at him well he his father had one
of the first cars in Long Island called
the Orient buckboard it was a wood made
car back in 1903 and it was made in
Brockton Massachusetts so he looked
angles by God that's the same car that
we had of course he climbs over the
ropes
and jumps in the thing like this all the
Curie's what are you doing what are you
doing so I said how come no so you know
he figured he'd had the privilege to
touch things like that and it was
fantastic and one last thing he said to
me I said so he came up to our house on
the Cape one day and he and gene were up
there lounging relaxing in our living
room I said so how all the people you
studied who the parties the people you
you you you're most intrigued by or or
that was one of your levels of reference
that he liked the most and he said the
Aborigines and I said really and he said
yes and I said why is that he said
because to me they were they were the
the most comfortable in their own skin
and so when he said that to me I look in
the mirror and I say you know I try to
look at the mirror myself every day for
five minutes and it's hard to do
sometimes but I said you know so he
inspired me to think about that and when
they're not looking at the heritage
plantation I do jump on that truck or
that car oh thank you
[Applause]
hi I'm Greg soot go I'm uncle house
nephew it was my brother I'd like to
speak about well here's the Halcon one
of the nicest men you'll ever meet it's
a great uncle I really loved him he I
wish to speak briefly about the three
people were probably the most
significant in the first half of his
life that would be his parents and his
wife Jean who was also very wonderful
they were both extremely generous to our
family house father was also a college
professor Howard Stern Conklin jr. and
as Lou and his mother Mae a Walton
Collier Conklin was a kindergarten
teacher she passed away young before she
saw any of her grandchildren in 1953 at
the age of 57 of bone cancer his father
would live to 1986 to 93 me 93 years old
I just want to briefly mention that
Howard Conklin is was the most stand-up
decent guy I ever met and got to know he
had two children my mother and how four
years older than mom and they were just
a great time leader conference they grew
up in Patchogue Long Island 7/10 of mile
seven tenths of a mile away from Long
Island Sound and it was like the perfect
upbringing
they always stressed education the
importance of a good education the
importance of the house curiosity was
natural they came out of him it's what
it's more than genetics because he was
so so interested in everything and I
miss him I just missed the heck out of
him
thank you very much Jean Jean me a
Kimura suey
Conklin grew up in Sharon Pennsylvania I
met her parents Bruce and marks other
grandparents and they were wonderful
people too and she gave up what could
have been a great career in biology she
had a master's degree in biology to be
his right-hand assistant and there's no
way he said he would have been success
without her but he was a super success
with her so here's to Aunt Jean Howard
Conklin and May Walton Collier coffee
thank you
[Applause]
thirty-five years ago I came to Yale
from Rice University and within a
semester I was unexpectedly thrust into
the chair of the Department of
Anthropology and it was a system that I
was unfamiliar with and difficult to
discern we had a department that was had
been aptly described by Mike Smith as a
group of dinosaurs people who were not
always on the same page and interested
in the welfare of the department as
opposed to individuals but in any event
the important thing is with hell that he
not only helped me understand the social
organization of the department and the
political dynamics of the department but
he also helped me immensely when I had
to testify before the senior
appointments committee this is one of
these strange rituals that Yale
University has where the chair of the
department goes before a group of ten
tenured professors and lays out the
reasons why a person should be promoted
and I had not been through a system like
that and I didn't know how it worked and
so hell took me into his office and he
sat me down and he got out his files his
little paper cards that gene had so
carefully arranged and went through
chapter and verse who the people were
what their strong points were how I
should make my pitch and and it worked I
mean it it was quite remarkable I the
first time I went in it was sort of a
mechanical process for me kind of
repeating hell's worse but I began to
realize that how really understood and
was able to give the kind of information
and advice that was abstention to try to
keep the program going to get people
promoted
and for that I'm greatly indebted and of
course in the years later on many
occasions he gave me good counsel he
quizzed me incessantly about things that
I didn't know and I wished I had but in
any event he was a good friend and we're
dearly miss him
thank you
[Applause]
Thanks
so my toast is to the person who
welcomed me so warmly to the
anthropology department in 1972 I I was
a lecturer I did not yet have my PhD in
hand how was this incredibly
distinguished professor and of course I
thought he was very old I now realized
he was decades younger than I am now but
never mind anyway he was old and he was
distinguished and he he was so welcoming
and he was so very interested in my work
in Madagascar and my research in
Madagascar and over a period of time he
asked me many things and led me I think
completely inadvertently
I know completely inadvertently and
deeply kindly to a deep appreciation of
my own utter ignorance about Madagascar
and about many other things besides he
knew so much about so many things my
toast is to that person my toast is to
the person who I when I became chair of
the anthropology department in 1986
would sit me down in his office in 51
Hill has and as someone said this idea
that there he would start with a single
person and from that person would
blossom an entire universe of
anthropology but it wasn't just a
universe of people it was also the
conceptual universe of the nature of
anthropology and he deepened and
broadened my understanding of what
anthropology was about and was deeply
wise as well as deeply erudite
my toast is to the person who when I
became Provost loaned me a beautiful
textile Ithaca textile to hang behind my
desk in the rather ominous Provost's
office which many of you will know that
it's all wood panels and very door as a
Provost's office should be so I had this
wonderful text file that hung on the
wall and of course how not only agreed
to loan it but he then micro managed its
installation it was just so behind my
desk I don't think that he ever knew how
often metaphorically I took that text
file down from the wall and wrapped
myself in it to remind myself that I was
really an anthropologist and all of this
was some kind of passing nightmare in
the process of it so my toast well you
know there is the toast of the person
who always with a post-it and with the
number two what I've learned there is
the number two pencil with the notes
saying a thought you and Bob would find
it this interesting would append it
attach it to a reprint and I would find
it in my pigeonhole was always
interested and always thinking about all
of us so at the end of the day my
toasters to a person who who was always
the same he was erudite he was wise he
was so kind we heard that this afternoon
he was so kind for me he was a kind
person and he was a person with the huge
laugh and an impossible expensive desire
to make phone calls we know we got that
but
I'm he is some mentor is not the word
for it I think for all of us he's a
person who just changed our lives
opened our minds and to me the heart of
how was somebody whose passion and
enthusiasm for anthropology and for life
and for people was just bottomless
endless it never it never ceased I never
found it in it and it was just you know
an amazing amazing than anyway my toast
is to how how
[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks
hi my name is al McCoy I teach Southeast
Asian history at University of Wisconsin
when I did my PhD here back in the 1960s
and early 1970s there's an Australian
novelist named David Malouf and he wrote
a novel called Johnno about a wild young
friend of his and he ends the novel by
saying that he went to the funeral in
this complex impossible difficulty Minh
being was being sent away in words or
all platitudes that seemed to float away
and extinguish rather than celebrate the
individual I paraphrase from memory so
there was another dimension to how yes
he was everything that everybody said he
was but there was a radical critical
insightful dimension to him he didn't
just record societies as they were I
think that that he somehow someway felt
like many good intellectuals that there
that there were serious problems and
particularly they came to the fore
during that decade when the United
States went to war in Vietnam in
Southeast Asia the region that he knew
and loved and spent most of his life on
and during that period this was a time
of tempest on campuses across the United
States the ROTC building was bachi
buildings were ROTC unit buildings were
being burned on campuses across the
United States I think it may have even
been burned here at Yale during that
period during the days of Rage when
there was protests over the Bobby sheep
trial students were packing up their
stereos and personal possessions and
fleeing and restoring the suburbs
waiting for the the hordes to come in
and ravage the college campuses we've
all heard how tile collected this
amazing array of artifacts and we've all
heard about his amazing office on
Hillhouse Avenue well in the spring of
1970 when the Cambodian riots for taking
place across the United States students
are being done
down across the country there were there
were riots campuses were being burned
Yale is in tempest during exit of the
day love days of Rage took place how was
heading off to Southeast Asia and in
those days I was part of a fairly active
any war movement on this campus I was
one of those dangerous and sin during
campus radicals that threatened the
property and the security of the
institution and I ran into Howe and he
we had a little talking so what are you
doing as well I said I'm actually
getting together with a bunch of the
anti-war activists on campus and we're
going to put together a book on Laos
Nixon has invaded Cambodia but that's a
tactical mistake what he's really got to
do to cut the Ho Chi Minh Trail which
what anybody has to do that have any
chance of winning this war he's got to
invade Laos and we're going to assemble
information we're going to put it
together in a book and we're and we're
going to bring it out to inform the
anti-war movement and how reached in his
pocket and said here the keys to my
office you know do your work there and
speaking of that phone bill that bill
Kelly spoke of my good heavens
did we make telephone calls we have
there were any war activists in
Southeast Asia that could be reached
most effectively by telephone we were on
the phone day and night the word dozen
of us that moved in Clarke Dairy Bar
takeaway remains of hamburgers and
french fries scattered across that
sacred terrain midst the the 100% rag
paper now if we go if we got words the
rare artifact hanging on the wall the
the mint photographs all of that were
taken over the scruffy band of raggedy
graduate students shall never protest it
in fact he was enormous ly pleased that
he had lent his resources to this
radical project of challenging and
perhaps in some way trying to correct
this mistake
so how was more than everything that's
everybody everybody said he had wisdom
he had a critical perspective on his own
society he lived a life and full and so
I'd like to toast to Hal Conklin a life
lived in full
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the other toast I think we can now
move to a we'll take a short short break
while we set up for a music and it's
sort of the equal Gauss section of the
program and that'll be the kind of last
organ organized portion of this or did
you want it you're going 200 Americo is
sorry America wants to make a toast to
start the ephah gal program I should say
that in eful gal there's a very small
area called by Nina and in vining on
there was a just across the right field
from us my mirto grew grew up and his
murmur toes father actually worked with
wood closely with our house endeavors
my father made me sort so I have to make
adjustment
I believe what somebody said upstairs
that hal hal like humor I'm not used to
calling him how because we call him
Cochrane in Medina but I also know him
as my in that's easy for girl names I'm
going to call him in but I believe what
I heard earlier that he liked humor you
like to laugh and I believe that he
studied a political because we are
humorous people unfortunately you had to
make me make you laugh here I cannot
just be humorous but anyway here is my
story
well a lot of you are applauding him
I used to carry anger and I shared this
when I did a ritual for him when he died
I used to carry anger because he
collected my favourite wooden spinning
top when I was a child it was my
favorite and it's probably here
somewhere in this museum
so I used to be angry at him and the
later on you know I used to be angry at
all of you scientists who collect bones
and study indigenous people I used to be
angry so I sort of was lost in my life
and it's speaking of laws have something
here that I care you know I'm wearing my
attire to honor my ancestors ah this is
a a shamanic blanket and this backpack
we call it a p.m. or passing in the
bontoc region this is to carry you know
when you go and work somewhere you put
your food here or anything that you need
you know tools that you need in the
field so let's see how traditional I am
this is a good book then if you read
this The Lost Tribe of Coney Island good
anthropological book
maybe dr. bubbly will talk just a little
bit about this about the Egret were
displayed here in the US and they were
called the circle The Lost Tribe of
Coney Island and I like to volunteer and
represent the descendants of these
people who are displayed here because I
once was lost myself and like I said I
used to be angry not at all in fact I
like your mother more Jean I think this
this Lobby but house were really helped
me find my home and that's why I'm
giving it us for him this evening so
thank you for inviting me this is what
we use in our tradition so there's
actually a ritual does perform when
somebody died after the person is buried
about a month or two months a shaman
will invoke his we'll call his spirit to
talk to him if there's anything that he
forgot any advice or anything that he
needs that the time that they will give
him or they will hear his advice and
then he will be sent off forever so I'm
going to give a toast for him and I'm
going to include his wife Jean
I'm going to say short prayer in if you
go Toyota Yamaha Natori Playa Hatano
pompom Ahana llamo Puea Thai Kumari
Chema Enoshima yo Tommy Nam JA ka kya
yo I'm otaku Lana into puree Nana na
hoona Mentos to llama thank you Fatima
yo yo yo man yo I I was vodka ha ha
Yamaha just anita guha I'm otaku
immediate animal Mugen particle momentum
of electron Kingdom Colorado
everybody joint
[Music]
[Applause]
is merdeen still here she said merdeen
said suddenly she said you know it takes
a she said you said two something
upstairs about it takes a village -
supposedly it takes a village to raise a
child well I have said and I thought I
was going to say this afternoon but I
forgot that it takes a family to raise
an anthropologist and much of that
family is here today and thank you
a sons included and now extended family
for making us all anthropologist and and
as from from that family I think he had
really an even broader family and and it
is the anthropological family which I
think was just as important to him as
you know well as all of us so from our
family we salute all of you and thank
you so much for coming
you
[Music]